مع وجود مأزق محتمل في ساحة
المعركة ، يبدو أن قادة كل من
أوكرانيا وروسيا يحاولون تحقيق النصر
في أي زعيم أكثر رجولية
من الرئيس الأوكراني الآخر
فلاديمير زيلينسكي الذي سافر إلى
مدينة بريستيج في الشرق محاطة من
ثلاث جهات من قبل القوات الروسية  حسنًا ، قام
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بزيارة
المناطق المحتلة من ابنها ،
ويسأل هانسك مباشرة كبار القادة عن
آرائهم حول المكان الذي
يقف فيه الهجوم الروسي كاتم الصوت نيك بيتر
موش.
دعم القوات في
الأراضي المحاصرة التي تواجه مشاكل مختلفة تمامًا ،
يقوم الرئيس بوتين برحلة نادرة
خارج روسيا إلى
المنطقة المحتلة جزئيًا لابنها في مقطع فيديو
نشره الكرملين ، وهو
يلتقي بكبار القادة يوم الإثنين ،
وهو أمر مهم بالنسبة لي للاستماع إليك
للاستماع إلى آرائك.  لمقارنة الملاحظات مع من
يتحدث إليه ، من المهم أيضًا
مقابلة قائد من نخبة
المظليين فيما يقول المحللون الغربيون إنه
قد يكون محاولة لرفع معنوياتهم في
أي يوم الآن ، ومن المتوقع أن
تشن أوكرانيا هجومًا مضادًا إلى حد كبير
في اتجاه أين
يقف بوتين أيضًا في لاهانسك
تحت الضغط أيضًا وانتقل الأسبوع الماضي فقط
إلى المنطقة الزمنية لموسكو حيث
تستمر روسيا في استيعاب الأماكن التي
تدمر الحرب فيها
مسؤولي كييف الذين سارعوا إلى اغتنام
الزيارة لتصوير شخص متهم بارتكاب
جرائم حرب يعود إلى مكان الحادث وهو
يصف  الرحلة كجولة خاصة في
الأراضي المحتلة والمدمرة
من قبل العقل المدبر للقتل الجماعي للاستمتاع
مرة أخيرة بالجرائم التي ارتكبها
شعبه
ربما تحمل مخاطر أكبر في
رحلته الأقل ندرة إلى بعض
الأجزاء الأكثر تضررًا من الجبهة الشرقية في زيارة
بلدة أبديفكا المدمرة بالكامل تقريبًا
تمنح الجوائز للقوات ،
لن يتضح بعد ما إذا كان قد رفع الروح المعنوية
بما يكفي لردع القوات الروسية
الآن على ثلاثة جوانب من المدينة ،
تحدث الأشياء بفضل اهتمامك بأن
مستقبلنا يعتمد عليك في
أوكرانيا.  تتزايد الخسائر لبعض
الجرحى الذين زارهم زيلينسكي ومنطقة
دونيتسك الثانية ، وتشير
التسريبات الأخيرة على ما يبدو من
البنتاغون إلى أن أكثر من
15000 جندي أوكراني قد لقوا حتفهم وأن
أنظمة الدفاع الجوي الرئيسية قد تنفد في الأسابيع المقبلة ، لكن كييف
تأمل أن تكون معدات أفضل.  السبب والتخطيط
قد يشهدان النجاح في هذا الهجوم المضاد الحيوي ،
رئيسان ، روحان مختلفتان تمامًا ، وحرب
واحدة لا تزال بلا نهاية ، نيك
بايتون والش ، سي إن إن ، شرق أوكرانيا.